we talk about the greatest weekend in
nfl history yes holy [ __ ] truly was
it truly was i wish i had nothing to do
this weekend so i could just [ __ ]
watch every game and do jack [ __ ]
every single game was good is tom brady
jesus
tom brady boy they got him yeah he's he
might you know what he lost but i think
the packers losing and aaron rodgers
losing showed us how good tom brady is
how great tom brady is
because aaron rodgers lost to a the san
francisco 49ers who were a good team but
they like they legit squeaked into the
playoffs they barely got in and the
packers were at home
in the snow which to be fair does
normally hurt a good quarterback and i
think if rogers leaves green bay for
like a dome he'll be on another [ __ ]
level even than what he already was but
you're still at home and he had with
five minutes left he had two drives to
seal or win the game
didn't do it either time went three and
out the first time i think three and out
the second time and that's how san
francisco won
so green bay's up ten to three they go
three and out aaron rodgers misses a
wide open receiver tries to force the
ball downfield they have to punt punt
gets blocked
return for a touchdown
ten all then he has another drive this
is his time at home to seal the win
let's [ __ ] hey i'm talking cash [ __ ]
about joe biden i'm doing interviews on
espn saying i'm canceled this is your
time to [ __ ] do it and then he flops
again
and then san francisco gets a ball back
and jimmy [ __ ] garoppolo drives down
for a game-winning field goal and aaron
rodgers lost talked all the [ __ ] in the
world took on everybody and [ __ ] lost
at home
the bucks were down 27-6
brady's offensive lines getting their
asses kicked all of his receivers are
hurt except for one who's playing hurt
the other two are gone a b left a
[ __ ] team his other guy chris goodwin
a godwin really good he's out for the
year touring acl brady fights back ties
the [ __ ] game and even though the
defense had forced a lot of turnovers
they blew a lot of coverages and at the
very end of the game uh they blow a
coverage and then matthew stafford
completes the pass and they went on like
be your own people bro i know and be
your own [ __ ] be your own that's why
he's jesus
the [ __ ] bucks defensive coordinator
is a judas bruh he judah's not a safety
is judas
he got destroyed in two straight plays
by the same guy by a cup cooper cop yeah
so cup killed him on that one play but
you can't single cover this guy well
look how good he is yeah oh no beckham's
not even complaining about not getting
the ball
because he's like this guy is the truth
he's the truth and him and stanford got
a crazy connection
odell beckham just over there getting
touchdowns when he gets him and it's all
good he hasn't once complained about not
getting the ball he played with jarvis
landry in cleveland who's a beast and
he's here and he's like hey this guy
might be mvp he gets the ball is he that
good white wide deceiver that wide
receiver
people are talking about him as mvp you
said julian edelman
don't do that
yeah
that is
100 okay in terms of like athletes i get
i get that's why it's important to you
but cooper cup this is different cooper
cup is legit people are talking about a
receiver's mvp that doesn't happen often
ever
i can i never remember one winning and i
can remember like two or three times
i've even talked about it in my lifetime
wow i remember uh calvin johnson and
then like probably jerry rice way back
in the day or something probably
but this guy is [ __ ] incredible
and he just beat brady that's how good
he is he beat brady i mean dude brady
did everything man
i watched the end of it and i was
screaming on the plane yeah oh my god
and like i mean it was just unbelievable
i couldn't when brady tied the game also
great play call to tie the game on the
run rush leonard fournette had a great
game but great play call tie the game i
won fear with most of these games oh
they left him too much time 14 seconds
that was the chiefs game 13 seconds oh
how many how much time did they leave it
was like 40 seconds for the ram
something like that yeah it was like 40
seconds a little bit more a minute maybe
it was it was more time but the chiefs
game is legitimately the best playoff
game i've ever seen in my life i need
you to go over the chiefs game because i
missed the chiefs game okay but just to
wrap up the tom brady discussion it was
like it's just such a letdown that he
did exactly what he needed to do yeah to
maintain his legacy yeah and this bum
safety got ripped twice like first of
all how do you even design a defense
that allows the best receiver in the
league the mvp to go one-on-one with
your safety that's what everybody's
saying in the [ __ ] corner so here's
the thing that you when you blitz you
know you got 11 guys in a football team
when you blitz you send more people at
the quarterback but then there's less
people covering receivers right
everybody's asking why do we need to
sack the quarterback if they got a
complete basically a 30-40 yard pass to
get into field goal range just cover the
receivers i think the the argument
behind that is it's going to make the
quarterback pass yeah but if you give
him more time his guys can get further
down the field but if you've got mad
people 30 yards downfield
he he'll pick up 15 16. it won't be
enough time yeah you play the sidelines
ideally and then you play the deep route
so you just let him have the middle of
the field yeah and then you'll see if
you can get this done you probably can
but they did let him out of the middle
field that's where he completes yeah but
then play d and the second don't send
extra extra defenders playing deep yeah
so you have a guy over the top when
cooper cup is running deep and then that
guy can break well that guy [ __ ]
bummed it up because the guy they did
have him deep it was the safety they
have a second guys he pressed yes it's
like what are you doing yeah you shot it
back pedaling you have a guy pressing
and another guy yeah so press him so he
can't even yeah but really
yeah exactly and like i mean it was just
an absolutely horrendous question what's
crazy is tom brady there's a quote i saw
during the game it came up where people
are saying he might retire and he's
saying like he says in the quote uh i
don't know if we're gonna win i don't
think we're gonna win the super bowl
this year he like says it blatantly i
don't think this is the year we win the
super bowl
which is crazy because i think he knew
this team has beat the [ __ ] up yeah we
got it last year i think a lot of people
are content with that i might not be but
a lot of people are we brought everybody
back so you didn't get to replace those
guys with new hungry [ __ ] yeah
there's an honor in defending it but
only to a point yeah you start getting
beat up it's like
these other guys are hungry they've
never been the rams never been matthew
stafford this is his first real shot at
a super bowl yeah so he's in it he's
about it let's go
you